Cassidy's 10, fifth grade. At the end of the school year, he's one of the talented extroverts singing in front of everybody, parents and kids, with his band.
卡西迪今年10岁，上五年级。学年结束时，他作为乐队的一员，在所有家长和孩子面前引吭高歌，表现得极具天赋且自信外向。
(SINGING) I love rock and roll. So come and take your time and dance with me!
（歌唱）我爱摇滚乐。所以来吧，花点时间跟我一起跳舞！
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
OK, but here's something that's hard for him-- reading. He'll be OK for stretches, when he already knows the words.
好的，但他有一件事做得比较吃力——阅读。如果书里的词他已经认识，那他还能勉强读上一段。
One day the sun shone, so it was not cold-- so cold.
有一天太阳照耀着，所以天气不冷——不冷。
But he has dyslexia. So reading an unfamiliar word, he has to decode it.
但他患有阅读障碍。所以每当读到不认识的词时，他都必须对其进行解码。
If it's a big word that I've never seen before, like that word-- I don't know what that says.
如果是一个我以前从未见过的大词，就像那个词——我不知道它怎么读。
OK, let's walk through that one.
好了，我们来拆解一下那个词。
Wait, deh, E. Deh, whip. Deh, eh, vu, ah.
等等，deh，E。Deh，whip。Deh，eh，vu，ah。
Here, talk me through what you're doing. So you're getting the deh.
来，跟我讲讲你在做什么。所以你得到了deh。
Deh. I had to-- if you didn't-- in the recording, you might hear me say "bed."
Deh。我不得不——如果你没听到——在录音里，你可能会听到我说“bed”（床）。
Thinking of the word "bed" is a way to keep B's and D's straight. This is actually one of the toughest things for Cassidy to learn, B's and D's, when they're not capitalized.
想到“bed”这个词是区分B和D的一种方法。对于卡西迪来说，这其实是最难学的知识点之一，尤其是在字母没有大写的时候。
B's and D's, they look the exact same, but just flipped! If you take a B, it can also be a D. And it was just super annoying for a long while.
B和D看起来一模一样，只是翻转了过来！如果你拿一个B，它也可以变成一个D。很长一段时间里，这真的非常烦人。
So it's easy to get them confused.
所以很容易把它们搞混。
Yeah.
是的。
So there's this trick that lots of people with dyslexia are taught. They picture the word "bed," which, if you think about it, kind of looks like a bed. The posts of the B and the D are like the footboard and the headboard of the bed. And then the E is kind of the mattress.
所以很多阅读障碍者都被教过这样一个窍门。他们在脑海里想象“bed”这个词，如果你仔细想想，它看起来确实有点像一张床。B和D的竖线就像床的脚踏板和床头板。而中间的E就像床垫。
I picture the letters. And I go buh for B, eh, and then duh. And then boom.
我在脑海里描绘这些字母。我读buh代表B，eh，然后duh。然后，砰，成了。
There are so many little rules and tricks like this that some kids with dyslexia use. They have all kinds of names-- the fizzle rule, the floss rule, short vowel protectors, welded sounds. These are the rules of the English language that most of us somehow absorb, but we are not aware of-- the mechanics of when to use a long vowel or a short vowel, when G or G-H are silent. They learn dozens of these and then wield them like tools, one after another, to decode how our words should sound.
像这样的小规则和窍门还有很多，有些患有阅读障碍的孩子会用到。它们有各种各样的名字——fizzle规则、floss规则、短元音保护者、焊接音。这些都是英语语言的规则，我们大多数人不知不觉就掌握了——我们并不了解什么时候该用长元音或短元音，什么时候G或G-H不发音的机制。他们学会了数十种这样的规则，然后像工具一样一个接一个地使用它们，来解码单词的发音。
And then eh, E, vuh.
然后是eh，E，vuh。
Anyway, back to decoding this word.
好了，回到这个词的解码上来。
Ah, deh, vuh, ah, ss.
Ah，deh，vuh，ah，ss。
Which, by the way, the word he's trying to read is "devastating."
顺便说一下，他正试图读的单词是“devastating”（毁灭性的）。
Devas--
Devas——
What is V-A-S-T? How would that sound?
V-A-S-T怎么读？听起来会是什么样？
Wait, oh, vast! Devast--
等等，哦，vast！Devast——
Mm-hmm, then A-T.
嗯哼，然后是A-T。
And then at, in. Devastin. Hmm? I think I'm doing something wrong.
然后是at，in。Devastin。嗯？我觉得我哪里做错了。
He tries breaking the word down syllable by syllable, like his teacher taught him. Explains one part of the word is a CVC-- consonant, vowel, consonant. He looks for parts of the word that he recognizes.
他试着像老师教的那样，逐个音节地拆解单词。他解释说单词的一部分是CVC结构——辅音、元音、辅音。他寻找单词中自己认识的部分。
I know ING from class and devasting.
我在课上学过ING，还有devasting。
You're leaving out the middle one, though.
但是你漏掉了中间的那部分。
Devas, at, ing. Devast-- I really don't know.
Devas，at，ing。Devast-ing。我真的不知道。
You're very close. You want me to give you a hint?
你非常接近了。你想让我给你个提示吗？
Sure.
当然。
OK, this one is a long A. So it's a-ting.
好的，这个A是长元音。所以是a-ting。
Devast, ate, ing. Devast-ate-ing.
Devast，ate，ing。Devast-ate-ing。
Do you know that word, devastating?
你认识那个词吗，devastating？
Devastating! I do know that word.
Devastating！我认识那个词。
That is so much work.
这真的太费劲了。
It is. It really is.
确实如此。
Later, I asked his teacher, what rule might have gotten him there? And she said, magic E. If you recognize that the ING in "devastating" might have been replacing an E on the end of the word, that final E would have told him how to pronounce the tate in "devastate." So many rules to remember and, irritatingly, so many exceptions to the rules you have to memorize.
后来，我问他的老师，什么规则能帮他读出来？她说，魔法E规则。如果你认识到“devastating”里的ING可能取代了单词末尾的E，那么那个末尾的E本可以告诉他如何发“devastate”中tate的音。有太多的规则要记，而且令人恼火的是，还有太多的例外情况需要死记硬背。
For example, "salmon." It would be pronounced sal-mon, but it's salmon. Like, why? There's so many words that are like, deal with it.
比如“salmon”（鲑鱼）。按理说应该读作sal-mon，但实际上读作sam-on。就像，为什么？有太多的词都是这样，只能接受现实。
And so Cassidy is in this situation where things that seem to come so easily to other kids, he has to work so much harder at. Kids like him can become as fluent in reading as anybody else, but it's like, to go to the mile that other kids go, they go 10 miles and need every navigation tool and touch every blade of grass along the way before they get there. Other kids really don't understand this.
所以卡西迪正处于这样一种境地：对于其他孩子来说轻而易举的事情，他必须付出多得多的努力。像他这样的孩子也可以和其他人一样达到阅读流畅的程度，但这就好比，别的孩子走一英里就能到达的地方，他们得走上10英里，而且需要每一件导航工具，还要仔细触摸沿途的每一株草才能到达终点。其他孩子真的无法理解这一点。
Yeah, they're like, why can't you read that? And I'm like, I have dyslexia. I mean, it doesn't feel terrible. It's not like, ahh, making me want to scream. But it's a little like-- I mean, I'm so used to it now that it's like, OK.
是的，他们会问，你为什么读不出来？而我说，我有阅读障碍。我是说，感觉并不糟糕。它不会让我想要尖叫。但感觉有点——我的意思是，我现在已经习惯了，所以觉得，好吧。
You know what's so strange? It's like, you have to master stuff that's so much more difficult than those kids.
你知道什么很奇怪吗？就是你必须掌握的东西比那些孩子难得多。
Definitely, definitely. I have to do a lot more just to get a simple word that everybody knows how to spell, except for me. It's just like, OK, well, have fun being able to spell supercalifragilisticexpialidocious. And I'm over here like, how do you spell "there" again?
绝对是，绝对是。我必须做更多的工作才能拼写出一个每个人都知道怎么拼的简单单词，除了我。这就好比，好吧，当你能拼出“supercalifragilisticexpialidocious”（超级加利弗雷吉利斯蒂克埃尔皮阿里多修斯）的时候去玩吧，而我却在这里想着，那个“there”到底怎么拼来着？
Well, today, on our program, we have people like Cassidy who have to take the long road to get to a place that other people get to more quickly. It takes them more time. It's more effort. But the thing about doing it that way, you don't take anything for granted. You see so much more than other people do. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
好了，今天在我们的节目中，我们将讲述像卡西迪这样的人，他们必须走漫长的道路才能到达别人能更快到达的地方。这需要他们花费更多的时间，付出更多的努力。但以这种方式行事的特别之处在于，你不会把任何事情视为理所当然。你看到的东西比别人多得多。这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, "Voter Reformed." So Mississippi is one of a small number of states where something like a robbery conviction can cost you your right to vote. Even after you get out of prison, even after you complete your parole, pay all your fines, all that, you still can't vote.
第一幕，“选民改革”。密西西比州是少数几个因抢劫罪定罪就可能让你丧失投票权的州之一。即使在你出狱之后，即使在你完成了假释、支付了所有罚款之后，你仍然不能投票。
Mississippi is unusual in that regard. Most states do not permanently take away a person's right to vote. And if they do, it's usually just for crimes like rape or murder. But in Mississippi, there is one way-- one long, winding path that people can take that will let them vote again. This is the path that most states do not offer. Johnny Kauffman explains.
密西西比州在这方面很特殊。大多数州不会永久剥夺一个人的投票权。即使剥夺，通常也仅限于强奸或谋杀等罪行。但在密西西比州，还有一种方法——一条漫长而曲折的道路，可以让人们重新获得投票权。这是大多数州不提供的途径。强尼·考夫曼来为大家解释。
When I first learned about this, I was a little baffled. To get your voting rights back, you have to get your own personal bill passed by the state legislature. These bills-- they're called suffrage bills-- are just one page with your name, your conviction, and a line about being a, quote, "honorable citizen," kind of your own personal law giving you permission to vote. The bills have to go through committees and pass the House and Senate, all that stuff. And we'll get to that.
当我第一次了解到这一点时，我感到非常困惑。要恢复你的投票权，你必须通过州立法机构通过一项属于你个人的法案。这些被称为“选举权法案”的法案只有一页纸，上面写着你的名字、你的定罪情况，以及一行关于你是“光荣公民”的内容，这就像是你自己的一部个人法律，给予你投票的许可。这些法案必须经过委员会，并在众议院和参议院获得通过，所有这些程序。稍后我们会谈到。
But the thing to know in general about this is, it's pretty hard to pass any bill, ever, about anything. So this is pretty hard. And the people that try, they tend to really care about voting, like this man, Gerald Laird. One of the main reasons he really wants to be able to vote again, the thing that drives him kind of crazy--
但关于这一点，总的来说你需要知道的是，无论什么法案，想要通过都非常困难。所以这非常难。而那些尝试的人，往往非常看重投票，就像这个人，杰拉德·莱尔德。他非常想重新获得投票权的主要原因之一，让他感到极其抓狂的一件事——
They consolidated the schools.
他们合并了学校。
--local school board. He talked for almost 10 minutes about it, how they closed the high school.
——当地校董会。他花了将近10分钟谈论这件事，谈论他们是如何关闭高中的。
And they moved the high school to Bassfield. Prentiss had the better facilities.
他们把高中搬到了巴斯菲尔德。普伦蒂斯明明有更好的设施。
And the school board members, he says, OK, they have credentials, but no real experience with education.
他说，校董会的成员们，他们虽然有资历，但对教育没有任何实际经验。
I mean, come on. My degree is in psychology. But that doesn't mean I would make a great teacher.
我是说，算了吧。我有心理学学位。但这并不意味着我会成为一名出色的老师。
Gerald lives an hour south of Jackson, Mississippi's capital, where he helps run the family business, a funeral home. Gerald told me he's an introvert, but he also said he's the person at church who will stand up and tell the deacon to get closer to the microphone. Gerald's the guy who sits in the back and records the service.
杰拉德住在密西西比州首府杰克逊以南一小时车程的地方，在那里他帮助经营家族生意，一家殡仪馆。杰拉德告诉我他是一个内向的人，但也说他是教堂里那个会站起来告诉执事靠近麦克风的人。杰拉德就是那个坐在后面录制仪式的人。
He's pretty open about, well, pretty much everything, including how he lost his right to vote. He robbed a bank back in 2002. He told me he was grappling with drug addiction, relapsed, and bought cocaine from a guy. It was that guy's idea.
他对自己几乎所有的事情都非常坦诚，包括他是如何失去投票权的。他在2002年抢劫了一家银行。他告诉我当时他正在与毒瘾抗争，复吸了，并从一个人那里买了可卡因。那是那个人的主意。
He wrote the note, and he said, go give this to the teller. And she gave me the money. And tell you how dumb I was-- instead of running out, I casually walked out.
他写了那张纸条，说，去把它交给柜员。然后她给了我钱。告诉你我当时有多蠢——我没有跑出去，而是悠闲地走了出去。
He wasn't wearing a mask. He didn't even know what was on the note.
他当时没戴面具。他甚至不知道纸条上写了什么。
I'm assuming it said, "Give me the money." That's what I'm assuming.
我猜上面写着，“把钱给我。”我是这么猜的。
They got caught the same day. At first, he was charged with armed robbery. But then the prosecutor looked at the security footage and realized he didn't have a weapon.
他们在同一天被捕了。起初，他被控武装抢劫。但后来检察官查看了监控录像，意识到他并没有携带武器。
And they were like, oh, OK. You're guilty of a lot of things. And being dumb is the most prevalent one. That's what my lawyer told me.
他们当时就说，噢，好吧。你犯了很多罪。而其中最普遍的一项就是愚蠢。这是我的律师告诉我的。
These days, Gerald watches after his mom and his uncle, who owns the funeral home. He's been out of jail for 16 years. He doesn't see any reason why he shouldn't be able to vote. Gerald started on this long, strange journey to get back his right to vote one day in church. A friend told him about the suffrage bills.
如今，杰拉德照顾着他的母亲和拥有殡仪馆的叔叔。他已经出狱16年了。他不明白自己为什么不能投票。杰拉德在教堂的一天开始了他重获投票权的漫长而奇怪的旅程。一位朋友告诉了他关于选举权法案的事。
So he decided to try. He filled out a form. A non-profit in Jackson passed it on to a state representative, who introduced his bill. Gerald hadn't actually seen it when we met, but I had a copy with me. It was wild for him to see it, House Bill 1721, an act to restore the right of suffrage to Gerald Laird of Jefferson Davis County, Mississippi.
所以他决定试一试。他填了一份表格。杰克逊的一家非营利组织把它转交给了一位州众议员，后者提交了他的法案。我们见面时，杰拉德实际上还没见过这份法案，但我随身带着一份。看到它对他来说太不可思议了，众议院第1721号法案，一项恢复密西西比州杰斐逊戴维斯县杰拉德·莱尔德选举权的法案。
Be it enacted by the legislature of the state of Mississippi, Section One, the right of suffrage is hereby fully and completely restored to Gerald Laird, Jefferson Davis County, Mississippi.
密西西比州立法机构颁布，第一节，杰斐逊戴维斯县杰拉德·莱尔德的选举权在此全面完全恢复。
To be clear, this bill hadn't passed. But just to see what could happen, there on the page--
明确一下，这项法案还没有通过。但只要看到在那张纸上可能发生的事情——
The right is hereby fully and completely restored. This makes me happy. This makes me really, really happy. Wow. Just imagine. Fully and completely.
权利在此全面完全恢复。这让我很高兴。这让我真的，真的很高兴。哇。简直无法想象。全面且完全。
What do you think about this line at the end, "The legislature is informed that he has since conducted himself?"
你觉得最后这一行“立法机构获悉他此后一直表现得”怎么样？
"As a law-abiding and honorable citizen in a good and lawful manner." I agree. I have, except for speeding. I have a problem with speeding, but I'm getting better. Mm, this would be just so amazing. And all it has to do is pass. Can I have a copy of this?
“作为一个守法和光荣的公民，以良好和合法的方式”。我同意。我确实是，除了超速。我在超速方面有问题，但我正在好转。嗯，这会是多么令人惊叹啊。而它所要做的仅仅是获得通过。我可以要一份复印件吗？
You can keep that.
你可以留着它。
OK. Wow.
好的。哇。
This year, Gerald was one of 23 people who got bills introduced, hoping to get the right to vote back. I tried to talk to as many as I could. It was a pretty determined group-- a dad and tool factory worker who had been on a union board; an older man who was sick in bed, used to be a county supervisor; and a guy who worked at a mental hospital. He showed me a news clipping about how his father was shot and nearly killed trying to register people to vote.
今年，杰拉德是23名获得法案提交、希望重获投票权的人之一。我尽可能多地尝试与他们交谈。这是一个非常坚定的群体——一位父亲和工具厂工人，曾担任工会理事；一位生病卧床的老人，曾是县主管；还有一个在精神病院工作的人。他向我展示了一份新闻剪辑，报道了他的父亲在试图登记人们投票时被枪杀并险些丧命。
There's something like 44,000 people in Mississippi who can't vote because of a conviction. A disproportionate percentage, 60%, are Black, in a state that's 38% Black. Gerald is Black. So is Nsombi Lambright-Haynes. She's the person who took the form Gerald filled out and gave it to a legislator who introduced the bill. She helps a lot of people do this.
在密西西比州，大约有44,000人因为定罪而无法投票。一个不成比例的百分比，即60%，是黑人，而在这样一个黑人占38%的州里。杰拉德是黑人。恩松比·兰布赖特-海恩斯也是。她就是那个拿走杰拉德填写的表格并交给提交法案的议员的人。她帮助很多人做这件事。
When I first learned about the process, I understood that people didn't take advantage of it. And I felt like, hey, this is a way for us to really get in there. And I was excited about it, until I learned that it was a joke.
当我第一次了解到这个程序时，我以为人们并没有利用它。我觉得，嘿，这是我们真正参与进去的一种方式。我对此感到兴奋，直到我得知这简直是个笑话。
A joke because a bill can die with no explanation. There's nothing on any government website telling you how to get your vote back, even finding out when the bills are discussed.
之所以是个笑话，是因为法案可能会莫名其妙地夭折。没有任何政府网站会告诉你如何恢复投票权，甚至很难找到讨论这些法案的时间。
How do you find out when the committees are happening?
你是怎么发现委员会什么时候召开的？
I would just text some of the committee members to see, have you heard anything about the suffrage committee? Oh, yeah. The chairman said we're probably going to meet next Wednesday. But it's never on the calendar. So then that next Wednesday would come. Are you guys going to meet today? Yeah, we're going to meet at 4:00 today. So it's just like, stalking people, basically.
我通常只是给一些委员会成员发短信看看，你们听说了关于选举权委员会的任何消息吗？噢，是的。主席说我们下周三可能会开会。但日历上从来没有写。然后那个周三就到了。你们今天打算开会吗？是的，我们今天下午4点开会。所以这基本上就像是在跟踪别人。
Fortunately, when Nsombi stalks people, they like her. She's fun to talk to. They answer her texts. Nsombi was head of the Mississippi ACLU for nearly a decade. Now she leads a nonprofit called One Voice. The office is in an old Masonic building that the civil rights activist Medgar Evers used to work out of. Nsombi seems busy all the time. A friend gave her this mug once that says, "Fuck it. I'll do it." And this is one of those things. She's got lots of other stuff, but she makes time for these bills-- been doing it for over a decade.
幸运的是，当恩松比跟踪别人时，他们喜欢她。她谈吐风趣。他们会回她的短信。恩松比曾担任密西西比州美国公民自由联盟（ACLU）负责人近十年。现在她领导着一家名为“同一个声音”的非营利组织。办公室位于民权活动家梅德加·埃弗斯曾经工作过的一栋古老的共济会建筑里。恩松比似乎一直很忙。一位朋友曾送给她一个杯子，上面写着，“去他的。我会搞定的。”这就是其中之一。她还有很多其他事情要忙，但她会抽出时间处理这些法案——这事她已经做了十多年了。
The lifetime voting ban is enshrined in the Mississippi constitution. And the history of how it ended up there is pretty well documented and revealing. It starts after the Civil War. Black people could finally vote, and they were putting people in office, including the first Black US senator, Hiram Rhodes Revels.
终身投票禁令被写入了密西西比州宪法。关于它最终如何被写入宪法的历史记录相当完备且发人深省。它始于内战之后。黑人终于可以投票了，他们开始让人们就职，包括第一位黑人美国参议员希拉姆·罗兹·里弗尔斯。
But there was backlash. In 1890, white leaders like Senator James George said the state needed to hold a convention to write a new constitution. George said the new census was going to show there were more Black people than whites in Mississippi. And the goal of the convention should be to make sure whites controlled the government.
但遭到了反扑。1890年，像詹姆斯·乔治参议员这样的白人领袖表示，该州需要召开制宪会议来起草一部新宪法。乔治说，新的普查将显示密西西比州的黑人比白人多。会议的目标应该是确保白人控制政府。
The president of the convention was a man named Solomon Calhoun, who said, quote, "Negro suffrage is an evil, and an evil to both races." In his opening speech at the convention, he said the voting scheme should be arranged to keep white people in power. They decided on a few things. There was a poll tax and this really vague test called the understanding clause that said a voter had to be able to interpret part of the constitution. One newspaper called it a gigantic fraud. Then there was the part of the new constitution about crime and voting.
会议主席是一个名叫所罗门·卡尔霍恩的人，他说，“黑人投票权是一种罪恶，对两个种族都是罪恶。”他在会议的开幕词中说，投票方案的安排应该旨在保持白人的权力。他们决定了几件事。有一项人头税和这项被称为“理解条款”的非常含糊的测试，该条款规定选民必须能够解释宪法的一部分。一家报纸称之为巨大的欺诈。然后是新宪法中关于犯罪和投票的部分。
The constitution says that there are 11 crimes that take your voting rights away. And those are bigamy, timber larceny--
宪法规定有11种犯罪会剥夺你的投票权。其中包括重婚罪、木材盗窃罪——
Timber larceny?
木材盗窃罪？
Yeah, yeah, like stealing wood or something, stealing trees.
是的，是的，就像偷木头什么的，偷树。
I talked to two historians who said the list was clearly meant to target Black people, crimes delegates at the convention thought Black people would be more likely to commit. And the novel idea that you could get your rights back if you get a bill through the legislature with your name on it, that was also in the 1890 constitution.
我和两位历史学家谈过，他们说这份名单显然旨在针对黑人，会议代表们认为黑人更有可能犯下这些罪行。而且，你可以通过一项以你名字命名的法案来恢复权利的这种新奇想法，也出现在1890年的宪法中。
Historians don't know much about how it ended up in there. Maybe they were trying to keep the governor from gaining too much power. Or maybe they wanted a way to help their white friends and family if they happened to commit one of the crimes on the list. Whatever it was, this last chance is still there for anyone who wants to try. But most people don't even know about it.
历史学家们对它最终如何出现在那里知之甚少。也许他们是试图阻止州长获得过大的权力。或者也许他们想要一种方法来帮助他们的白人朋友和家人，如果他们恰好犯了名单上的罪行的话。不管怎样，这个最后的机会对于任何想要尝试的人来说依然存在。但大多数人甚至不知道它。
Gerald's journey began where all epic journeys begin-- the subcommittee of the House Judiciary B Committee. Gerald wanted to be there when they discussed his bill-- which, it turns out, is difficult to do because you don't know when the heck they're meeting. Even the legislators don't know sometimes.
杰拉德的旅程始于所有史诗般的旅程开始的地方——众议院司法B委员会小组委员会。杰拉德想在他们讨论他的法案时在场——但结果发现，这很难做到，因为你根本不知道他们什么时候开会。甚至连立法者有时也不知道。
I managed to get the phone number of the lawmaker who chairs the committee, but it wasn't until the day before that he let me know when it was going to happen. Gerald wasn't going to be able to make it. He couldn't find anyone to cover for him at the funeral home. I visited him the night before. We sat in his living room.
我设法得到了委员会主席这位议员的电话号码，但直到前一天他才让我知道什么时候会发生。杰拉德没能赶上。他在殡仪馆找不到人替班。我在前一天晚上拜访了他。我们坐在他的客厅里。
It's kind of emotional for me because this is something that I would really, really, really like to see happen. And left up to a bunch of people that don't know me from a can of paint, I don't know what my chances are. If I were able to be there, I'd say I would at least have a 75% chance if I could meet them and talk with them.
这对我来说有点情绪化，因为这是我非常，非常，非常想看到的事情。如果交给一群根本不认识我的人来决定，我不知道我的胜算有多大。如果我能亲自去那里，我会说，只要能见到他们并与他们交谈，我至少有75%的胜算。
Are you nervous about how it's going to go tomorrow?
你对明天会发生的事情感到紧张吗？
Yes, extremely. I had a joke, but it's not appropriate. But yeah, very.
是的，非常紧张。我有个笑话，但不适合说。但是是的，非常紧张。
You can tell me the joke.
你可以告诉我那个笑话。
As nervous as a $2 whore on first Sunday.
像一个在星期天礼拜日感到紧张的两美元妓女。（译注：原意为形容极度紧张）
It seemed like Gerald's bill stood a chance of passing. Sometimes the bill fails because the person has an unpaid fine they don't know about or because they only recently finished their sentence. Those weren't problems for Gerald. I told him I'd let him know how it went.
杰拉德的法案似乎很有希望通过。有时法案因为当事人有未缴清的罚款而失败，或者因为他们最近才服完刑期。这些对杰拉德来说都不是问题。我告诉他我会让他知道结果如何。
I went to the hearing the next day. Six state representatives, all but one of them white, sat around a couple of folding tables in a big committee room that was mostly empty. Off to the side, a red plastic coffee dispenser with Styrofoam cups. The legislators had background checks in front of them for everyone with a suffrage bill. Only like three other people were in the room. I set a microphone on the table.
第二天我去了听证会。六名州众议员，除一人外全是白人，坐在一间几乎空无一人的大委员会会议室里的几张折叠桌旁。旁边放着一台带泡沫塑料杯的红色塑料咖啡机。立法者面前放着每个有选举权法案的人的背景调查资料。房间里只有大约三个人。我把麦克风放在了桌子上。
Sam, you ready?
萨姆，准备好了吗？
Yeah.
好了。
All right, we're going to start the meeting.
好的，我们要开始会议了。
This is Representative Noah Sanford. They went through suffrage bills. The first bill passed. So did the next one. There wasn't really any discussion. Then Gerald's came up.
这是诺亚·桑福德议员。他们逐个审议了选举权法案。第一项法案通过了。接下来的一项也通过了。并没有什么真正的讨论。然后轮到了杰拉德的法案。
All right, 1721. This is Gerald Laird of Jefferson Davis County.
好了，1721号。这是杰斐逊戴维斯县的杰拉德·莱尔德。
Sanford read through the bill.
桑福德读完了法案。
So we're 13 years past at this point. Y'all have any questions? All right, motion is title sufficient to pass. All in favor?
所以我们现在已经过去了13年。你们有什么问题吗？好吧，动议标题足以通过。所有赞成的？
Aye.
赞成。
Any opposed? OK, 1721 passes.
有反对的吗？好吧，1721号法案通过。
House Bill 1721, Gerald's bill, made it out of the committee. The next day, it went to the full House for a vote.
众议院第1721号法案，杰拉德的法案，从委员会出来了。第二天，它提交众议院全体会议表决。
All right, that brings us to page 30, suffrage bills.
好吧，这让我们进入第30页，选举权法案。
For a suffrage bill to pass, it takes more than a normal bill, like to adjust income tax rates or give teachers a raise. You need more than a majority. 2/3 of the House would have to vote for it. And then, if it passed here, 2/3 of the Senate.
要让选举权法案通过，它需要的不仅仅是普通法案，比如调整所得税率或给老师加薪。你需要超过多数票。众议院2/3的票数必须投赞成票。然后，如果在这里通过了，参议院也需要2/3票数。
House Bill 1721 concerns Gerald Laird of Jefferson Davis County convicted of robbery in 2003, was released, and finished all the conditions of his sentence May 2009. That's the description of the bill.
众议院第1721号法案关于杰斐逊戴维斯县的杰拉德·莱尔德，2003年因抢劫罪被定罪，获释，并于2009年5月完成了刑期的所有条件。这就是法案的描述。
Questions? I don't see any. Open the machine, madam clerk. Question occurs on House Bill 1721. You favor the bill, vote aye. If you're opposed, vote nay. Has everyone voted? Close the machine, madam clerk. By a vote of 106 yays, 0 nays, the bill passes. Next item.
有问题吗？我看没有。打开机器，秘书女士。问题出现在众议院第1721号法案上。赞成该法案的，投赞成票。反对的，投反对票。每个人都投了吗？关闭机器，秘书女士。以106票赞成，0票反对，该法案通过。下一项。
106 representatives voted for Gerald's bill. Nobody voted against it. It was through the House. It just had the Senate to go.
106名代表投票赞成杰拉德的法案。没有人投反对票。它通过了众议院。只差参议院了。
Hey, did you hear that your bill passed the full House?
嘿，你听说你的法案在众议院全体会议通过了吗？
Oh, wow. That's wonderful. OK. That's great! Wow. Man. Now, on through the Senate. I can't wait. Woo. They need to have some elections this summer so I can vote.
噢，哇。太棒了。好的。那太棒了！哇。天哪。现在，进入参议院了。我等不及了。呜。他们今年夏天需要举行一些选举，这样我才能投票。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
Wow. I wish you could see this big cheese-eating grin on my face right now.
哇。我真希望你能看到我现在脸上那灿烂的笑容。
Next step, the Senate. It started the following week. Just like on the House side, Gerald's bill had to be passed by a committee before it could go to the full senate. He had been trying on his own to reach the chair of the committee, Senator Joey Fillingane. He thought it might help his case.
下一步，参议院。它在接下来的一周开始。就像在众议院一样，杰拉德的法案必须在提交参议院全体会议之前先由委员会通过。他一直在努力通过个人努力联系委员会主席乔伊·菲林格恩参议员。他认为这可能有助于他的案子。
I tracked down his number today, the actual number that actually rings to his office. However, no one ever answers it. Because I think it rang somewhere in the neighborhood of 50 times, and then it hung up on me.
我今天查到了他的号码，那个真正能打到他办公室的号码。然而，从来没有人接听。因为我想它大概响了50次左右，然后就挂断了。
You let it ring for 50 times? You stayed on that long?
你让它响了50次？你就一直等着？
I did, yes. I wanted to tell him my name and that I would appreciate any consideration that he would give my suffrage bill so that I could get my voting rights back.
是的，是的。我想告诉他我的名字，并且我会感激他对我选举权法案的任何考虑，以便我能恢复我的投票权。
The Senate committee met a few days later. Again, we only learned about it the night before. And like last time, Gerald couldn't go because of work. He had to watch it on YouTube from the funeral home. This committee room was slightly bigger, fancier than the first one. It was the end of the session. And only six of the committee's 15 members showed up. All of the ones who did were white. Here's Senator Fillingane.
参议院委员会几天后开会。我们同样只在前一天晚上才得知。而且像上次一样，杰拉德因为工作没能去。他只能在殡仪馆通过YouTube观看。这个会议室比第一个稍微大一点，也更高级一点。那是会议快结束的时候。委员会的15名成员中只有6名露面。所有到场的都是白人。这是菲林格恩参议员。
So our friends from the House who are here this morning, we have three suffrage bills that are before us. And the colleagues from down the hall were kind enough to come down and visit with us.
所以我们今天早上在这里的众议院朋友们，我们面前有三项选举权法案。走廊那头的同事们很客气地过来拜访我们。
They were going to be considering just three suffrage bills. The first bill came up. It wasn't Gerald's. The sponsor from the House talked about it, and the committee passed it. Then another representative came to the microphone. She was there to talk about two other bills.
他们只考虑三项选举权法案。第一项法案提出来了。不是杰拉德的那项。众议院的发起人谈了谈，委员会通过了。然后另一位代表走到麦克风前。她来谈论另外两项法案。
Good morning, committee, and thank you, Mr. Chairman, for allowing me to present on behalf of Ms. Leadbetter and Ms. Grant.
早上好，委员会，谢谢你，主席先生，允许我代表莱德比特女士和格兰特女士进行陈述。
Neither bill was Gerald's. His did not even come up. It was dead. I looked into it, and this is how it goes a lot of the time. The House will pass a suffrage bill, but then Fillingane blocks it. So I put in a request to talk to him. Gerald called me the day after his bill died.
两项法案都不是杰拉德的。他的甚至都没有被提出来。它夭折了。我调查了一下，很多时候就是这样。众议院通过一项选举权法案，但菲林格恩随后将其封杀。所以我提出了与他交谈的请求。杰拉德在他法案夭折的第二天给我打了电话。
I did not call you yesterday because I was somewhat depressed and kind of a little bit just like, oh, well. I guess this wasn't meant to be right now.
我昨天没给你打电话，因为我有点沮丧，觉得，噢，好吧。我想这在现在注定不会发生。
What do you mean by that, just saying, oh, well?
你这话是什么意思，只是说，噢，好吧？
I mean, that's kind of my way of protecting my feelings, by just saying, it's not in God's time.
我是说，这是我保护自己感情的一种方式，只是说，时候未到。
Gerald had no idea why Fillingane killed his bill, why these other people made it and not him. Fillingane got back to me and was happy to talk. I met him in his law office. He's a real estate lawyer when he's not at the Capitol.
杰拉德根本不知道为什么菲林格恩扼杀了他的法案，为什么其他人成功了而他没有。菲林格恩回了我的话，很高兴交谈。我在他的律师事务所见到了他。他不在国会大厦时是一名房地产律师。
I just finished my 23rd year in the legislature on combined House and Senate. And next year will be the end of the sixth term. So I mean, I've been doing it for a little while now.
我刚刚结束了我在立法机构的第23个年头，包括众议院和参议院。明年将是第六任期的结束。所以我的意思是，我已经干了一段时间了。
I brought a copy of Gerald's bill with me.
我带了一份杰拉德法案的复印件。
His did pass out of the House. And then I don't think the Senate committee even brought it up for discussion.
他的确实在众议院通过了。然后我想参议院委员会甚至没有拿出来讨论。
Right, I don't recall us bringing that one up, and probably because his disenfranchising crime was that of robbery, which is considered a violent offense.
对，我不记得我们提出过那一个，可能因为他被剥夺权利的罪行是抢劫，这被视为暴力犯罪。
Robbery is classified as a violent offense in Mississippi law. It doesn't mean the crime itself was necessarily violent, but Fillingane has a general rule-- doesn't consider any suffrage bills for violent crimes. He says that's what the lieutenant governor, who put him on the committee, told him to do. That's why Gerald's bill died.
在密西西比州法律中，抢劫被归类为暴力犯罪。这并不意味着犯罪本身一定是暴力的，但菲林格恩有一条通用规则——不考虑任何暴力犯罪的选举权法案。他说这是任命他的副州长告诉他这么做的。这就是杰拉德的法案夭折的原因。
But ultimately, it is up to Fillingane. He can do what he wants. And he said he does sometimes weigh information that sways him one way or another. But there's no part of this process set aside for people to come talk to him in the committee, introduce themselves, tell their story. I told them that Gerald's crime was almost 20 years ago and that he didn't have a gun at the bank.
但最终，决定权在菲林格恩。他想怎么做就怎么做。他说他有时会衡量影响他偏向哪一方的信息。但这个过程中没有一部分是专门留给人们在委员会里与他交谈、自我介绍、讲述他们故事的。我告诉他，杰拉德的罪行发生在近20年前，他在银行时没有带枪。
Fillingane said, yes, those are the kinds of things that could persuade him in the committee. But he said he'd look at other things, too. Fillingane said it might hurt someone like Gerald if the police had been called to their home or if they'd been convicted of another crime. I wondered how Fillingane felt about enforcing this particular part of Mississippi's constitution, given how it disproportionately affects Black people and given its history.
菲林格恩说，是的，这些确实是可能说服他在委员会中支持的事情。但他表示他也会看其他事情。菲林格恩说，如果警方曾被叫到某人家里，或者他们曾被判犯有其他罪行，可能会伤害像杰拉德这样的人。考虑到密西西比州宪法的这一部分如何不成比例地影响黑人，并考虑到其历史，我很好奇菲林格恩对执行这一特定部分有什么感觉。
The historians that I've talked to about this to try to learn more about it said that it was this 1890 constitutional convention that met, and that the goal of that convention was to keep Black people from voting, and that these criminal disenfranchisement, these laws, were a part of that plan.
我与之交谈过的试图更多地了解这一点的历史学家们说，是1890年的制宪会议达成了这一目标，而会议的目标是阻止黑人投票，而且这些剥夺刑事权利的法律是该计划的一部分。
I don't know if that's the case or not. I wasn't there. I've not studied the history of the 1890 constitution. And certainly, Mississippi has a very checkered past when it comes to race relations. We treated African-Americans very poorly in some parts of our history. And I'm certainly not going to sit here and defend that or even try to. I wouldn't want to. But if you're asking me, is the suffrage right being treated differently based on your race in 2022 as it relates to suffrage bills that we consider in the legislature, absolutely not.
我不知道情况是否如此。我当时不在那里。我没有研究过1890年宪法的历史。当然，密西西比州在种族关系方面有着非常坎坷的过去。我们在历史的某些部分对待非裔美国人非常糟糕。我当然不会坐在这里为之辩护，甚至试图辩护。我不想这么做。但如果你问我，在2022年，关于立法机构考虑的选举权法案，选举权利是否因种族而受到不同对待，绝对不是。
I don't even know the race of the person. I'm sure I could probably try to find out by asking Department of Corrections to print me a social history, the person's age, and racial background, and all of that if I wanted to. I've never done that. I don't intend to start. But I mean, it's not obvious to me, just by looking at a bill, what racial background someone is a part of.
我甚至不知道那个人的种族。我相信我肯定可以尝试通过要求惩教署为我打印社会历史、个人的年龄、种族背景等信息来找到答案，如果我想的话。我从来没这样做过。我不打算开始。但我的意思是，我看一眼法案，并不明显地知道某人的种族背景是什么。
I asked him about this rule more broadly. If someone does their time, they're out of prison, off parole, years have passed, why shouldn't they be allowed to vote?
我问了他关于这项规则更广泛的问题。如果一个人服完刑，出狱了，结束了假释，多年过去了，为什么他们不被允许投票？
What's the reasoning behind that?
这背后的理由是什么？
Well, I think not necessarily what I would think, but we--
嗯，我想不一定是我会怎么想，但我们——
Oh, but I'm curious about what you think.
哦，但我很好奇你怎么想。
I mean, I think at some point, personal responsibility has to come into it. And you have to realize, if I'm going to break the social contract and commit a violent crime-- most of these are violent crimes that lead to disenfranchising your right to vote-- there are prices to pay for that. There hasn't been a groundswell of public support to change this particular aspect of our state constitution. Not to say that there won't be in the future, but certainly, there hasn't been as of 2022.
我的意思是，我想在某种程度上，个人责任必须参与其中。你必须意识到，如果我要打破社会契约并犯下暴力罪行——大多数导致剥夺投票权的都是暴力犯罪——那么为此付出代价是必须的。目前还没有改变我们州宪法这一特定方面的公众支持浪潮。并不是说将来不会有，但可以肯定的是，到2022年为止，还没有。
Of course, the thing about public support is that the people directly affected by this provision in the 1890 constitution, they can't vote. This year, just five people got their right to vote back, which is pretty typical. This year, it's four women and one man. I don't know much about them because I couldn't reach them, just what's on their suffrage bills. Two were convicted of forgery, two of embezzlement, and one burglary. Most of them finished their sentences before Gerald did. Some of them hadn't been able to vote for decades.
当然，关于公众支持的一点是，那些直接受到1890年宪法这一条款影响的人，他们无法投票。今年，只有五个人恢复了投票权，这很典型。今年是四名女性和一名男性。我对他们了解不多，因为我联系不到他们，只有他们选举权法案上的内容。两人因伪造罪被定罪，两人因挪用公款被定罪，一人因入室盗窃被定罪。他们大多数人完成刑期的时间比杰拉德还早。他们中的一些人已经几十年无法投票了。
There's a lawsuit in the federal courts trying to argue that this whole process for getting the right to vote back is arbitrary, and therefore, unconstitutional, as in the US Constitution. But it's in the early stages. And any ruling could take years. Nsombi, the woman who helps get a lot of these bills introduced, told me she's basically stuck, trying to get as many of them through the House and Senate as she can, one by one, using the very process she doesn't think should exist in the first place. Gerald told me for sure he was going to try again. He still has the copy of his bill that didn't pass.
联邦法院正在进行一项诉讼，试图论证恢复投票权的整个过程是武断的，因此违宪，即违反了美国宪法。但这还处于早期阶段。任何裁决可能都需要数年时间。恩松比，那个帮助推动提交许多法案的女性，告诉我她基本上被困住了，试图通过众议院和参议院推动尽可能多的法案，一个接一个，使用她认为根本不应该存在的这个过程。杰拉德肯定地告诉我他会再试一次。他仍然保留着那份没有通过的法案副本。
It's in my bedroom. I see it every day. Right now, it's attached to my mirror. But at some point, I am going to more than likely put it in a frame and keep it in my room.
它在我的卧室里。我每天都能看到它。现在，它贴在我的镜子上。但在某个时候，我很有可能会把它装进镜框里，放在我的房间里。
Why did you put it on your mirror?
你为什么把它放在镜子上？
I want to see it so I can see the progress. See the progress. It passed the House. And to me, that's an accomplishment. That means that I'm still halfway there.
我想看着它，这样我就可以看到进展。看到进展。它通过了众议院。对我来说，那是一个成就。这意味着我还在路上一半。
A few months later, we talked again. And he told me he'd been arrested for cocaine possession. He didn't have to tell me about it. But he did, just volunteered it. He said he was driving a friend, and they got pulled over. Gerald says his friend had the cocaine. The police report says both of them did. In any case, Gerald was angry at himself for having gotten into that situation.
几个月后，我们又谈了一次。他告诉我他因持有可卡因被捕了。他没必要告诉我这件事。但他还是说了，主动提出来的。他说他在开车送一个朋友，他们被拦下了。杰拉德说他的朋友有可卡因。警方报告说他们两人都有。无论如何，杰拉德对自己陷入那种境地感到生气。
Drug possession is not a crime that's on the list of things that will cost you your right to vote. It wasn't in the 1890 constitution. But based on what I learned from Senator Fillingane, Gerald's arrest might be enough reason to kill his bill. If the point of putting this in the constitution was to make it a long journey for people like Gerald, it's working.
药物持有并不是那种会让你丧失投票权的犯罪清单上的罪行。它不在1890年的宪法里。但基于我从菲林格恩参议员那里学到的，杰拉德的被捕可能足以成为扼杀他法案的理由。如果将这一点写入宪法的目的是为像杰拉德这样的人制造一段漫长的旅程，那么它是有效的。
Johnny Kauffman is a senior producer at Campside Media. Coming up, a truck that's speeding down a California highway with 100,000 passengers inside. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
强尼·考夫曼是Campside Media的资深制作人。接下来，一辆在加州高速公路上超速行驶的卡车，载着10万名乘客。那将在芝加哥公共广播电台一分钟后讲述，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, The Longest Distance Between Two Points, stories of people who have to take the long and, sometimes, absurd way to arrive somewhere that should be so straightforward to get to. We've arrived at Act Two of our show. Act Two, "Ill Communication."
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，“两点之间最长的距离”，讲述了那些必须走漫长且有时荒谬的路才能到达本应直截了当的目的地的人们的故事。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“病态交流”。
In this act, we turn to a story of somebody who starts at home and then ends up at home with a long, time-consuming journey in the middle. This whole thing happens in China. I guess you've probably heard just how different and fantastically aggressive China's response to COVID has been. From the start, they shut down entire cities, and it got results. Best estimates are that China has had fewer than 20,000 people dead from COVID versus, as you know, a million here.
在这一幕中，我们要讲述一个故事，一个人从家里出发，然后在中间经过漫长的耗时旅程后又回到了家。这一切发生在发生在中国。我想你可能听说过中国对新冠疫情的反应是多么不同和疯狂。从一开始，他们就封锁了整个城市，而且取得了成效。最好的估计是中国死于新冠的人数不到2万人，而正如你所知，我们这里有100万人。
And when Omicron arrived, China treated it with the same severity as the earlier variants, even though 90% of the population is now vaccinated. They locked down all of Shanghai in April. And lockdown in this case means really locked down. Over 25 million people could not leave their apartments or homes. Grocery stores and food delivery was shut down. Lots of people couldn't get food or medicine. It was pretty awful. This lasted for two months.
当奥密克戎变异株到来时，中国以与早期变异株相同的严重程度对待它，尽管90%的人口现在已经接种了疫苗。他们四月份封锁了整个上海。在这种情况下，封锁确实意味着锁死。超过2500万人无法离开他们的公寓或家。杂货店和食品外卖被关闭。很多人得不到食物或药物。这真的很糟糕。这种情况持续了两个月。
And we still haven't gotten much of a glimpse of what it was like to live through that. So I was excited to talk to Yang Yi about this thing that happened to him and his boyfriend during that period. Yang is a podcast producer in China, lives in Shanghai. And one day, early in the lockdown, he did his daily required self-test, as usual.
我们仍然没有真正了解到在那段期间生活是什么样的。所以我很高兴能与杨毅谈谈在此期间他和他的男朋友身上发生的事情。杨是一位中国的播客制作人，住在上海。封锁初期的一天，他像往常一样进行了每日必需的自我测试。
But that morning, I saw two lines.
但在那天早上，我看到了两条线。
Two lines.
两条线。
Yeah.
是的。
You had COVID.
你得了新冠。
Yeah. I think, wow, that's bad. And I tell my boyfriend, Johnny. And he tests and is positive, too.
是的。我想，哇，这很糟糕。我告诉了我的男朋友，强尼。他也进行了测试，结果也是阳性。
Anybody in China who tests positive is required to report it to the government, which, in Johnny and Yi's case, means calling one of their neighbors, a very kind retiree who is the person in their apartment building designated to deal with government on all matters, getting new elevators installed, dealing with a blocked sewer, whatever. So they call her.
在中国任何测试呈阳性的人都必须向政府报告，在强尼和杨的案例中，这意味着给他们的邻居打电话，一位非常善良的退休人员，她是被指派负责处理他们公寓大楼所有政府事务的人，安装新电梯、处理下水道堵塞等等。所以他们打电话给她。
And then they figure, within a couple of hours, the government's going to send somebody to take them to a quarantine center that's part of China's zero tolerance policy. Unhealthy people are separated from the rest of the population.
然后他们估计，在几个小时内，政府会派人带他们去作为中国零容忍政策一部分的隔离中心。不健康的人被与其余人口隔离。
And then, the next very urgent order of business-- they really don't have much time for this-- is figuring out where to send their dog while they're in quarantine. He's just a puppy, a five-month-old schnauzer. They had seen this video online that was being passed around of a corgi being killed, supposedly because its owner had COVID and had been sent to a quarantine center.
然后，接下来的非常紧急的业务——他们真的没有多少时间处理这个——是弄清楚在他们被隔离期间把狗送到哪里。他只是一只小狗，五个月大的雪纳瑞。他们曾在网上看到这段广为流传的视频，视频中一只柯基犬被杀，据说是因为它的主人得了新冠被送去了隔离中心。
So there's no way for a dog to go with them. And so I just cried. I just-- I don't know how to say-- I just crash, because I don't know what's next. It's such unpredictable. And the dog thing is a very clear thing we have to solve in several hours.
所以狗不可能和他们在一起。所以我只是哭了。我不知道怎么说——我崩溃了，因为我不知道下一步是什么。它是如此不可预测。而狗的事情是我们必须在几个小时内解决的一个非常明确的事情。
It's actually harder than you might think because the whole city is closed up. Johnny calls lots of places before he finally finds an animal hospital that can take their schnauzer. But then they have to find somebody who's authorized to drive a car in Shanghai with all the streets shut down. So a friend knows some professional freight drivers, and they help with that. And then, they have to find somebody who's allowed to walk from their apartment building to the car to hand the dog to the driver. It takes a government official to arrange that. Finally, the dog is delivered into the car. Yi and Johnny can start packing, figuring somebody's going to come for them any minute to take them to the quarantine center.
这实际上比你想象的要难，因为整个城市都关闭了。强尼在最后找到一家可以接收他们的雪纳瑞的动物医院之前打了许多地方的电话。但随后他们必须找到一个获准在上海街头所有街道关闭的情况下驾驶汽车的人。所以一位朋友认识一些专业的货运司机，他们在那方面提供了帮助。然后，他们必须找到一个获准从他们的公寓大楼走到车边把狗交给司机的人。这需要一位政府官员来安排。最后，狗被送进了车里。杨和强尼可以开始收拾行李了，想着随时会有人来带他们去隔离中心。
But things wasn't that simple. The truth is, no one came to us at first day.
但事情并没有那么简单。事实是，第一天根本没人来。
Or the second or the third. Someone calls from the Shanghai CDC to follow up, but didn't send anybody. Other officials call. More days pass. Finally, on the eighth day, they do their daily self tests, and they learn they do not have COVID anymore. And then that night, before dinner, they get the phone call.
第二天或第三天也没有。上海疾控中心的某人打电话跟进，但没人派来。其他官员打电话来。更多天过去了。最后，在第八天，他们进行了每日自我测试，并得知他们不再有新冠了。然后那天晚饭前，他们接到了电话。
The phone call, yeah, informing us that it's time to go.
那个电话，是的，通知我们是时候走了。
Over to the quarantine center.
去隔离中心。
Yes, in two hours, we should go to the curb with our luggage for the bus. And that bus would take us to the quarantine center.
是的，两个小时内，我们要带上行李到路边等车。那辆巴士会把我们带到隔离中心。
Oh, no. So do you tell them, that's fine, we're cured. We don't need to come?
噢，不。所以你告诉他们，没关系，我们已经治愈了。我们不需要去？
Yes, yes, of course. I say, OK, self-test is negative today. There's no need for it. And they say, oh, you guys have to go.
是的，是的，当然。我说，好的，自我测试今天呈阴性。不需要它了。他们说，噢，你们必须去。
What if you don't go?
如果你不去会怎样？
Who knows? I have no idea.
谁知道呢？我一点头绪都没有。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
They decide that it's smart to go because now they have this bureaucratic thing that they actually need to fix. China has these QR codes. Everybody has one on their phone. Red if you have COVID, green if you don't have COVID. Now theirs were red, meaning they wouldn't be able to go into any building or store or office or just anywhere when lockdown ended. That's the thing they thought the quarantine center could cure for them.
他们认为去是明智的，因为现在他们有一件官僚事务确实需要解决。中国有这些二维码。每个人的手机上都有一个。如果你有新冠是红色的，如果你没有新冠是绿色的。现在他们的是红色的，这意味着当封锁结束时，他们将无法进入任何建筑物、商店、办公室或任何地方。这就是他们认为隔离中心可以为他们治愈的事情。
And at that point, my thought is we want a healthy social identity back, not a healthy body.
在那一刻，我的想法是我们想要回一个健康的社会身份，而不是一个健康的身体。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Exactly. Even if your bodies don't have COVID, your QR code has COVID, and they can take care of that.
确实。即使你们的身体没有新冠，你们的二维码有新冠，他们可以处理那个。
Yes.
是的。
So, after a week, you finally go to the quarantine center. What's it like?
所以，在一周后，你们终于去了隔离中心。那是什么样的？
Actually, it is a high school gymnasium.
实际上，它是一个高中体育馆。
[DOCTORS SPEAKING IN CHINESE]
[医生讲中文]
And this is sound I recorded for my own podcast. And this quarantine center is for people with very mild symptoms or no symptoms at all. Most don't even need a doctor. So they just come here and rest and wait to get better.
这是我为自己的播客录下的声音。这个隔离中心是给那些症状非常轻微甚至根本没有症状的人准备的。大多数人甚至不需要医生。所以他们只是来到这里休息并等待康复。
[DOCTORS SPEAKING IN CHINESE]
[医生讲中文]
These are doctors telling us all where to go. You go to the first floor. You are first, you are second, you are third. OK, move forward.
这些是医生告诉我们大家去哪里。你们去一楼。你是第一批，你是第二批，你是第三批。好的，向前走。
Then what happens?
然后发生了什么？
My boyfriend and I go inside. They issued us toiletries, a washbasin, toothpaste, toothbrush, towel, a cup, and two packet of tissues.
我和我男朋友进去了。他们发给我们洗漱用品，一个洗脸盆，牙膏，牙刷，毛巾，一个杯子和两包纸巾。
Two packets of tissues.
两包纸巾。
And a sleeping bag. And we wait for check-in.
还有一个睡袋。然后我们等待办理入住。
It's like you guys are joining the army or something.
听起来你们就像是去参军什么的。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[讲中文]
Some people are sent to stay on the basketball court on the third floor. He and Johnny were pointed to the first floor, where they learned they'd be living in the swimming pool. There's no water in it. Instead, there were rows of cots, men in the deep end, women and children in the shallow end. Elderly people with mobility problems were on the edges of the pool. Because it was just a high school pool, there's only a tiny bathroom with one toilet in it for the men and another bathroom with one toilet for the women.
有些人被派去睡在三楼的篮球场上。他和强尼被指引到一楼，在那里他们得知将住在游泳池里。里面没有水。取而代之的是一排排帆布床，男的在深水区，妇女和儿童在浅水区。有行动障碍的老人在池边。因为这只是一个高中游泳池，男士那边只有一个带一个厕所的小浴室，女士那边有另一个带一个厕所的浴室。
But there are close to 200 people here now. So it's crazy. And there is no hot water in the shower.
但现在这里有近200人。所以这太疯狂了。而且淋浴间里没有热水。
Yi and Johnny figured they'd be there for four or five days. The rumor was, you needed two negative PCR tests to get out. And they give the tests every other day.
杨和强尼估计他们会在那里待上四五天。传言说，你需要两次阴性PCR测试才能出去。他们每隔一天进行测试。
It was late at night when we arrived. So we went straight to bed. So in a quarantine center, the lights do not turn off all night long.
我们到达时已经是深夜了。所以我们直接上床睡觉了。所以在一个隔离中心，灯光整夜都不会熄灭。
The lights don't turn off?
灯不会关吗？
And people around you watch TikTok all night long without headphones on.
而且周围的人整夜不戴耳机看抖音。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[讲中文]
OK, so that's you.
好吧，那是在你身上。
Saying it is now 10:40 PM on April the 17th. I'm laying on the cot. And you can hear what it sounds like around me.
说现在是4月17日晚上10:40。我躺在床上。你可以听到我周围的声音。
[NOISE]
[噪音]
Could you sleep? Could Johnny sleep?
你能睡着吗？强尼能睡着吗？
Well, frankly speaking, I can sleep, and I sleep well. But for Johnny, I think, oh, he's more sensitive during sleeping. So that noisy environment does not work for him. It's obvious he become more and more tired each day.
嗯，坦率地说，我可以睡，我睡得很好。但对于强尼，我想，噢，他在睡觉时更敏感。所以那种吵闹的环境对他不起作用。显然他每天变得越来越累。
That's not what really gets to Johnny, though. What kills Johnny about all this?
不过，这并不是强尼真正受不了的。到底是什么让强尼崩溃？
When Johnny realized that there is only one men's toilet. He just-- he broke down. He crashed. [LAUGHS] He just feel, it's such disgusting. It is not healthy.
当强尼意识到只有一个男厕所时。他只是——他崩溃了。他彻底崩了。[笑] 他只是觉得，太恶心了。这不健康。
He says that to avoid using the bathroom for, I'll just say number two, Johnny took steps, real steps.
他说为了避免使用厕所来解决，我会说，大号，强尼采取了行动，真正的行动。
Every meal, he just eat half. He just eat half. And the breakfast, the worker give us the bread, eggs, and the milk. He just eat a piece of bread, no eggs, no milk, something like that.
每一顿饭，他只吃一半。他只吃一半。早餐，工作人员给我们面包、鸡蛋和牛奶。他只吃一片面包，没有鸡蛋，没有牛奶，类似那样。
And is this typical of the two of you? He would get more freaked out about things, and you would be more calm?
你们俩一向如此吗？他会对事情更抓狂，而你会更冷静？
Well, he is born and raised in Shanghai. It's a big city. And everything is very clean, refined.
嗯，他是在上海出生长大的。这是一个大城市。而且一切都很干净、精致。
Oh, right.
噢，对。
Everything's fine.
一切都很好。
He's used to things being better.
他习惯了更好的东西。
Yes, yes. So but for me, it's different because I come from a small town. So I have to say, I have seen more dirty toilet than this. So for me, I think it was fine. It would be fine. Because I've seen worse.
是的，是的。所以对我来说，这不同，因为我来自一个小镇。所以我不得不说，我看过比这更脏的厕所。所以对我来说，我觉得还可以。这会好起来的。因为我看过更糟的。
You've seen worse.
你看过更糟的。
Yeah, I have seen worse.
是的，我看过更糟的。
The daily routine at the quarantine center, every other morning at 7:00, everybody would line up at the edge of the pool for a PCR test. When you finish your test, you get breakfast. Young people usually go back to sleep, he says. 7:00 AM is a little early for them.
隔离中心的日常生活，每隔一天的早上7点，大家都会在池边排队进行PCR测试。测试结束时，你得到早餐。年轻人通常会回去睡觉，他说。早上7点对他们来说有点早。
Pretty soon, their sleep is disturbed by housekeepers who come through spraying disinfectant everywhere, which is really, really loud, he says. He and Johnny would work, do remote meetings with their colleagues. And then when it's almost time for lunch, a nurse stands at the edge of the swimming pool and gets on a megaphone. And in that noisy, echoey room, people talking on their phones--
很快，他们的睡眠就被四处喷洒消毒液的管家打断了，这真的，真的非常吵，他说。他和强尼会工作，与同事进行远程会议。然后当快到午餐时间时，护士站在游泳池边用扩音器喊话。在那嘈杂、回音的房间里，人们在手机上交谈——
And suddenly, it gets very quiet because everyone knows the nurses are going to read the names of everyone who are allowed to go home.
突然，变得非常安静，因为每个人都知道护士要宣读那些获准回家的人的名字了。
And what's it like? What's the scene like?
那是什么样的？那是什么场景？
Well, that scene is very, very funny because the scene is a lot like a reality TV show. You know, those whose names are read cheer. And someone will say, woo! I get to go home! Something like that. And those who are not mentioned have disappointment, reaching all of their faces.
嗯，那个场景非常，非常有趣，因为这个场景很像一个现实电视节目。你知道，那些名字被读到的人会欢呼。有人会说，呜！我可以回家了！类似那样。而那些没被提到的人，失望写满了他们的脸。
After that, Yi says, everybody tries to figure out, why did that person get out? How many negative tests do you really need to get out?
在那之后，杨说，每个人都在试图弄清楚，为什么那个人能出去？到底需要多少次阴性测试才能出去？
And there is some gossip is here. Oh, that guy, he already leave, but I don't know. Maybe he's only got one negative, and he's leave. Oh, and that guy. He got two negatives, but his QR code is still red. So that is the main topics in the quarantine center. Everyone will say, oh, how many negatives you get? How many negatives are you get? What's your result? What's your result?
而且这里有一些流言蜚语。噢，那个人，他已经走了，但我不知道。也许他只有一次阴性，他就走了。噢，那个人。他得到两次阴性，但他的二维码仍然是红色的。所以这是隔离中心的主要话题。每个人都会说，噢，你得到多少个阴性？你得到多少个阴性？结果是什么？你的结果是什么？
And so how does this feel to you and Johnny? You're in this absurd situation. You don't have COVID. But they're keeping you in quarantine. You can't go home. Were you angry? Were you frustrated?
这对你和强尼来说感觉如何？你们处于这种荒谬的情况下。你们没有新冠。但他们把你们关在隔离区。你们不能回家。你们生气吗？你们沮丧吗？
I think we're not angry and frustrated because-- well, Ira, I have to say, we have no choice. We have no choice. We have to face the reality.
我想我们不生气也不沮丧，因为——嗯，艾拉，我不得不说，我们别无选择。我们别无选择。我们必须面对现实。
And the quarantine center, he says, wasn't all bad. In fact, a bunch of things were better than their life back home with the city on lockdown.
他说，而且隔离中心并没有那么糟糕。事实上，很多东西比他们在家中处于封锁状态的生活要好。
I don't have to worry about food anymore. Since the beginning of April, with everything on lockdown, it was hard to find food anywhere. All the stores were closed. Food delivery was completely shut down. And nobody stored enough food. We are hungry.
我不再需要担心食物了。自从四月初开始，一切都处于封锁状态，很难在任何地方找到食物。所有的商店都关门了。食品配送完全关闭。而且没有人储存足够的食物。我们很饿。
Really? You were hungry?
真的吗？你们很饿？
Yes, I'm hungry. But here, three meals are served here every day. Pork, beef, eggs, vegetables, and unlimited drinks and milk.
是的，我很饿。但在这里，每天提供三餐。猪肉、牛肉、鸡蛋、蔬菜，以及无限量的饮料和牛奶。
So that seems really important.
所以那看起来非常重要。
Yes, and another benefit of being here, we can move around, get some exercise. We're not allowed to leave our homes. And our tiny apartment is only 20 steps at most to walk from one end to the other. But there is a standard swimming pool here to walk around. It is 140 meters. And after each meal, you will see many people walk around the edge of the pool.
是的，来到这里的另一个好处是，我们可以四处走动，做些运动。我们不被允许离开我们的家。而我们的小公寓走动从一端到另一端最多只有20步。但这里有一个标准游泳池可以走动。它有140米。而在每一顿饭后，你会看到很多人在池边走动。
This is another thing. Back at home, Yi says, at their apartment building, people would only see each other when they went downstairs for the official COVID test. When they did that, everybody was pretty quick about it. Nobody would stay and chat, scared of getting infected.
这是另一件事。回到家，杨说，在他们的公寓大楼里，人们只有在下楼进行官方新冠测试时才会见面。当他们这样做时，每个人都很快。没有人会留下来聊天，害怕被感染。
But here, everyone is infected.
但在这里，每个人都被感染了。
Well, everybody but them. And they were all stuck together, so people talked and hung out. And you can just watch people, which he likes.
嗯，除了他们以外的所有人。而且他们都被困在一起，所以人们交谈和闲逛。而且你可以看着人们，这让他喜欢。
Yeah, I hadn't seen so many strangers in weeks! And what impressed me the most was a young couple.
是的，我已经好几周没见过这么多陌生人了！而最让我印象深刻的是一对年轻夫妇。
[GIGGLING] [SPEAKING CHINESE]
[咯咯笑] [讲中文]
This is me saying, they seem to be sunbathing. It's like, they're laying on the beach.
这是我说，他们看起来好像在日光浴。就像，他们躺在沙滩上。
Wait, because why? Explain their setup.
等等，因为为什么？解释一下他们的设置。
Oh, because they moved their cot to the side of the pool. And for them, so they were like the beach chairs, you know. And each laying there by the pool with a book in their hands.
噢，因为他们把帆布床搬到了池边。对他们来说，就像海滩椅，你知道的。每个人都躺在那里，手里拿着一本书。
Honestly, when you describe it this way, it doesn't sound so bad.
老实说，当你这样描述时，听起来并不那么糟糕。
Yeah, I feel that here in quarantine center, normal life is lived.
是的，我觉得在这里隔离中心，生活还在继续。
Other people Yi observed-- a middle-aged businessman, big guy, big voice, very pro-government. He would spout off after breakfast every day about politics at length, for everyone around him, like his own political talk show. On the cot next to him, a skinny university lecturer who Yi saw try to argue with the businessman one day, which, apparently, did not go very well. The business man just kind of drowned him out.
杨观察到的其他人——一个中年商人，大块头，大嗓门，非常支持政府。他每天早餐后都会就政治问题长篇大论，对周围的每个人讲，就像他自己的政治脱口秀一样。在他旁边的帆布床上，坐着一位瘦弱的大学讲师，杨曾有一天看到他试图与商人争论，这显然进展得不太顺利。商人只是用声音淹没了他的争论。
And then there was the guy who slept on the cot next to Yi. He was a source of fascination because, more than anybody in the quarantine center, he seemed the most desperate to get out, the most upset each day when he was not on the list to go home. Yi didn't know his first name.
还有睡在杨旁边帆布床上的那个人。他令人着迷，因为他似乎比隔离中心里的任何人都更渴望出去，每天当他不在回家名单上时就越沮丧。杨不知道他的名字。
I usually call him Wang. Clean cut, 26, worked as an English teacher in a kindergarten. And before I came to the quarantine center, he's already here for one week.
我通常叫他王。清爽，26岁，在幼儿园担任英语老师。在我来到隔离中心之前，他已经在这里待了一周了。
Wow.
哇。
And the day after I arrived, he had already gotten two negative test results, but they didn't let him leave.
而在我到达后的第二天，他已经得到了两次阴性测试结果，但他们不让他离开。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[讲中文]
That's Wang's voice, and he's saying he was getting desperate.
那是王的声音，他说他变得绝望了。
One of the ways that Wang deals with his anxiety over this, he never changes his clothes. He says that he's in the same red shirt and white socks every single day, even though he has a big suitcase by his cot.
王应对这种焦虑的一种方式是，他从不换衣服。他说他每天都穿同一件红衬衫和白袜子，尽管他的帆布床旁有一个大行李箱。
But he never opened that suitcase. And I ask him why. He tells me, he just wants to go home. He just wants to go home when the nurse read his name, and leave immediately and pack the suitcase. Maybe it will spend five or eight or 10 minutes. He don't want to waste up time. So he think, OK, maybe I don't open that suitcase.
但他从来没打开过那个行李箱。我问他为什么。他告诉我，他只是想回家。他只是想在护士读到他的名字时，立即离开并收拾行李箱。也许它会花费五到八或十分钟。他不想浪费时间。所以他想，好吧，也许我不打开那个行李箱。
Some nights, Wang stays up all night, worried that he's going to sleep through the PCR test at 7:00 AM.
有些晚上，王整夜不睡，担心自己会睡过早上7点的PCR测试。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[讲中文]
Here's Wang's voice, and he's saying, "I can't sleep all night. I was waiting. My mind was thinking all the time, go home, go home, go home. I was not even in the mood to watch TikTok anymore."
这是王的声音，他说，“我整晚睡不着。我在等待。我的大脑一直在想，回家，回家，回家。我甚至连刷抖音的心情都没有了。”
Finally, one morning, they read Wang's name. Yi says he was out of there in three minutes flat. Threw his sleeping bag and toiletries into the garbage, pulled his unopened suitcase out of there before Yi could get his phone number or say goodbye. Johnny and Yi got out the next day. They got the dog back. QR codes were fixed. They had started in their apartment, went on a six-day journey that was completely pointless, and delivered them back at the end of the road to the exact spot they had started, no better and no worse, though Yi says he's glad it happened.
终于，一天早上，他们读到了王的名字。杨说他在三分钟内就离开了那里。把睡袋和洗漱用品扔进垃圾桶，在他能拿到电话号码或说再见之前就拉着他没打开的行李箱出去了。强尼和杨在第二天出去了。他们找回了狗。二维码修好了。他们从公寓出发，进行了一次完全毫无意义的六天旅程，最后回到路终点，恰好回到他们出发的原点，没有更好也没有更坏，尽管杨说他很高兴这件事发生了。
I have to say, it feel like an adventure. It's just like an adventure. We got food. We could talk to the strangers. And that is the only chance during those weeks we could go outside apartment. We could go on the street.
我不得不说，感觉就像一场冒险。它就像一场冒险。我们有食物。我们可以和陌生人交谈。那是那些周里我们可以走出公寓的唯一机会。我们可以走在大街上。
When they're dropped off afterwards, it was at a crossroads near their place. And they walked through the empty streets to get home. Yi liked that. No cars, no people. Just cats, he says, just strolling in the middle of the street like they own the place. When would you ever see that? Or any of it? If he had a choice, Yi definitely would choose the experience they had. Johnny, however? No way.
当他们事后被送下车时，是在他们住处附近的一个十字路口。他们走过空荡荡的街道回家。杨喜欢那样。没有车，没有行人。只有猫，他说，像它们拥有这个地方一样在街道中间溜达。你什么时候会看到那样的情况？或者任何那样的情况？如果有的选择，杨肯定会选择他们拥有的那次经历。然而强尼？没门。
Act Three, "The Roe Less Traveled." So ladies and gentlemen, perhaps you remember the critique offered by a 10-year-old at the beginning of today's program about the way we spell the name of a certain fish, S-A-L-M-O-N.
第三幕，“少有人走的路”。女士们先生们，或许你们还记得今天节目开始时一位10岁小朋友对我们拼写某种鱼名字的方式所提出的批评，S-A-L-M-O-N。
It would be pronounced sal-mon, but it's salmon. Like, why?
按理说应该读作sal-mon，但实际上读作sam-on。就像，为什么？
Fair point. This last story is about salmon doing something about as logical as that spelling, taking a ridiculous route to get where they need to go. And by that, I mean a ridiculous route that is different from the normal kind of ridiculous route they usually take. Jaime Lowe went to California to see it for herself.
公平的观点。最后一个故事是关于鲑鱼做的事情，逻辑上和那个拼写一样荒谬，走着一条荒谬的路线到达它们需要去的地方。我的意思是一条荒谬的路线，与它们通常走的那些荒谬路线不同。杰米·洛亲自去加州一探究竟。
I have an above-average attachment to salmon, an obsession that began in college when I took a class with salmon guru Peter Moyle. He's famous in salmon circles, trust me. I think I was attracted to their epic migration and the macabre nature of their lives.
我对鲑鱼有着超乎寻常的依恋，这种痴迷始于我在大学时参加了鲑鱼大师彼得·莫伊尔的课程。他，相信我，在鲑鱼圈子里很有名。我想我是被它们史诗般的迁徙和它们生命中那种恐怖的本质所吸引。
They're born, wiggle around in a cold stream, make their way to the ocean, then instinctually, against all odds, return to the place of their birth, hurling their bodies over waterfalls, flesh rotting, dodging bear claws, simultaneously decaying as they're pushing towards their exact nook and their exact birth stream to lay eggs and let the cycle begin again. It's like they're dying to live.
它们出生，在寒冷的溪流中扭动，设法到达海洋，然后凭借本能，克服一切困难，回到它们的出生地，将身体投向瀑布，肉体腐烂，躲避熊爪，同时在向它们确切的出生溪流推行，去产卵并让周期再次开始。就好像它们拼死也要活下去。
I mean, there's this whole industry of nature documentaries centered on dramatizing the species and their odyssey, films which feature the sound of raging water in the background while a serious narrator describes their majesty.
我的意思是，有一整套以戏剧化这一物种及其奥德赛为中心的自然纪录片行业，这些影片以背景中湍急的水声为特色，同时一位严肃的叙述者描述它们的威严。
It's a game of persistence and luck. And although they fail time after time, their desire to push on is so strong, they never give up.
这是一场关于坚持和运气的游戏。虽然它们一次又一次地失败，但它们坚持推进的愿望是如此强烈，它们从不放弃。
It's a staple of nature porn. But the world has changed. The climate has changed. There's been increasingly hot temperatures, fires, drought, pollution. And many of the rivers salmon used for their migration have run dry or have been blocked by dams. That's why today, in California, many salmon follow a radically different course. They make their way to the ocean not through rivers, but inside a fleet of tanker trucks with human drivers at the wheel.
这是自然色情片的主打内容。但世界变了。气候变了。气温越来越高，火灾，干旱，污染。许多鲑鱼用于迁徙的河流已经干涸或被大坝阻断。这就是为什么今天在加州，许多鲑鱼遵循着完全不同的路线。它们不是通过河流，而是乘坐有人类司机驾驶的油罐车舰队前往海洋。
When I first heard about trucking salmon, it seemed so dystopic, a cold, mechanical process. The idea of salmon stuck in traffic just made me feel sad, like nature had been hijacked. But I was also kind of curious. I really wanted to see this Rube Goldberg, tin-cans-and-rubber-bands environmental hack in person. So I decided to follow five silver trucks transporting about half a million adolescent salmon on a 120-mile drive to the San Francisco Bay, a migration that no longer starts with the sound of babbling water. It's got a different sound.
当我第一次听说用卡车运输鲑鱼时，它看起来是那么反乌托邦，一个寒冷、机械的过程。鲑鱼被困在交通中的想法让我感到悲伤，好像自然被劫持了。但我也有点好奇。我真的很想亲眼看看这个鲁布·戈德堡式的、用锡罐和橡皮筋拼凑的环保黑客手段。所以我决定跟随五辆银色的卡车，运送大约50万条青少年鲑鱼，进行120英里的车程前往旧金山湾，一场不再以潺潺水声开始的迁徙。它有一种不同的声音。
[MACHINERY HUMMING]
[机器嗡嗡声]
Late one Tuesday afternoon, I found myself at the Mokelumne River Fish Hatchery, standing in front of a gas-powered machine that looked like it would be more at home on a construction site. The hatchery is about an hour northeast of Modesto in the Central Valley. It's rural and isolated, and so hot, the sun immediately burns, even in May. Mokelumne sits next to a river that was once known for thriving salmon and trout runs, but was dammed in the '60s. To offset the lost wild populations, the state built a hatchery and a parking lot close to the old stream bed.
周二傍晚，我发现自己站在莫凯勒米河鱼类孵化场前，站在一台看起来更适合施工现场的燃气机器前。孵化场位于中央谷地莫德斯托东北约一小时车程的地方。那里农村且孤立，而且太热，即使在五月，阳光也会立刻灼伤皮肤。莫凯勒米坐落在一条曾经以繁茂的鲑鱼和鳟鱼洄游而闻名的河流旁，但在60年代被筑坝了。为了抵消失去的野生种群，该州在旧溪床附近建造了一个孵化场和一个停车场。
I should say, hatcheries are controversial. The fish raised in them are not as prepared to survive in nature. And when they're released, they breed with native salmon, compromising the gene pool. There are people who think we shouldn't have hatcheries at all. But California has had them for decades at this point, a really long time. Mokelumne is not a massive operation, just a few bungalows and 20 concrete trenches packed with adolescent fish.
我得说，孵化场是有争议的。在其中饲养的鱼并没有做好在自然界生存的准备。当它们被释放时，它们会与本地鲑鱼杂交，损害基因库。有些人认为我们根本不应该有孵化场。但加州在这一点上已经持续了几十年，真的很长一段时间。莫凯勒米不是一个大型作业，只有几间平房和20个挤满了青少年鱼类的混凝土沟渠。
When I pull up, I meet the guy responsible for getting the salmon to the ocean. Bill Smith, the hatchery manager, greets me, then walks me over to this machine that's now so critical to salmon migration, and we try to talk over its roar.
当我停下车时，我遇到了负责把鲑鱼送到海洋的那个人。孵化场经理比尔·史密斯向我打招呼，然后带我走向这台现在对鲑鱼迁徙至关重要的机器，我们试着在机器的轰鸣声中交谈。
What is this?
这是什么？
This is a fish crowder.
这是一个鱼类挤压器。
A fish crowder?
鱼类挤压器？
Yeah. It's what we use to crowd the fish down.
是的。这是我们用来把鱼群挤过去的。
Oh, I see them!
噢，我看到它们了！
See all the salmon?
看见所有的鲑鱼了吗？
Yeah!
是的！
Yeah.
是的。
Bill's a big, bearded, burly guy. And the suspenders are not just for show. They hold up jeans which are tucked into waterproof boots. He's introverted, seems a little gruff. But there's a tenderness in the way he talks about the fish. In fact, he tells me, when these fish were just born, babies the size of fingernails, wriggling in the water, he would sometimes sleep at the hatchery overnight. He wanted to make sure their water was the right temperature, that the electricity stayed on. He wanted to make sure they were OK.
Do you feel emotional attachment to the fish after, because you basically--
比尔是一个高大、多须、魁梧的男人。背带不仅仅是装饰。它们支撑着塞进防水靴里的牛仔裤。他很内向，看起来有点粗鲁。但在他谈论鱼的方式中有一种温柔。事实上，他告诉我，当这些鱼刚出生时，只有指甲盖那么大的婴儿，在水中扭动，他有时会整晚睡在孵化场。他想确保它们的水温合适，确保电力没断。他想确保它们没事。
I don't know if you would call it that, but yeah, definitely an attachment. Pretty amazing animals.
你对比这些鱼产生过情感依恋吗，因为你基本上——
Yeah.
我不知道你是否会那样称呼它，但是的，绝对有依恋。非常了不起的动物。
It's comforting to know someone who cares is at the heart of this operation. Bill grew up in the area, a fisherman. His life revolves around raising these animals for harvest. But he rarely buys salmon in the store, says he can't afford it. He only eats what he catches.
是的。
He mounted the moving platform of the crowder and started in on his job. The crowder has a metal grate that dips below the water. It pushes the fish, each the size of a hot dog, to one end of the raceway. Then they're sucked up into a tube that's connected to the top of a truck. The tube was translucent. And I could see all these salmon whooshing by, like documents being transported in a pneumatic tube.
知道有这么一个关心它们的人处于这项运作的核心，让人感到安慰。比尔在该地区长大，是个渔夫。他的生活围绕着饲养这些动物以供捕获。但他很少在商店里买鲑鱼，说他买不起。他只吃他捕获的。
I wondered how they felt, if they felt. What did they think of the sudden rush of movement, the dramatic shift in their environment? One minute, shining in the sun, the next, dropped in a big, dark tanker. There was no way to really know. After Bill filled each truck with brackish water and fish, and bags of ice to maintain the temperature, we pulled out of the hatchery.
他登上了挤压器的移动平台，开始了他的工作。挤压器有一个金属格栅，浸没在水下。它把每一条热狗大小的鱼推到水道的一端。然后它们被吸进连接在卡车顶部的一根管子里。管子是半透明的。我可以看到所有这些鲑鱼像在气动管中运输的文件一样呼啸而过。
Goodbye, fishies.
我很好奇它们的感觉，它们是否会有感觉。它们对突如其来的运动、环境中剧烈的变化有什么看法？一分钟前，在阳光下闪耀，下一分钟，被扔进一个巨大的、黑暗的油罐里。真的没法知道。在比尔用咸水、鱼和几袋冰来维持温度装满每辆卡车后，我们驶离了孵化场。
We're on the road, me and 500,000 fish, and it's weird. Bill's driving ahead in a pickup. I follow behind the caravan. The five trucks look like any other fuel tankers you would see on the highway. They blend in seamlessly. You'd never know how many lives were speeding by in the lane next to you.
再见，小鱼们。
What's amazing is that even though the fish are traveling by truck, they'll still be able to trace their way back to their birthplace, the hatchery. The fish are imprinted with hatchery water, Bill told me. So if they survive long enough at sea to reach spawning age, they can use their sense of smell to return to him, swimming up rivers till they're at the stream bed by the hatchery.
我们在路上，我和50万条鱼，这很奇怪。比尔开着一辆皮卡车在前面。我跟在车队后面。这五辆卡车看起来和你会在高速公路上看到的任何其他油罐车一样。它们天衣无缝地融合在一起。你永远不会知道有多少生命在你旁边的车道上飞驰而过。
It takes 2 and 1/2 hours till the trucks finally pull in to their destination, Fort Baker. Nothing can happen until the dead of night because if the salmon are released when it's light out, seagulls, pelicans, and cormorants will circle, dive, and swallow as many of the 500,000 fish as they can. In front of us, the Golden Gate Bridge frames the San Francisco Bay, which glimmers against the skyline. They can't get very close to the water because the pier is a historic landmark.
令人惊奇的是，尽管这些鱼是通过卡车运输的，但它们仍然能够循迹回到它们的出生地——孵化场。比尔告诉我，这些鱼身上烙印着孵化场水的记忆。所以如果它们在海上生存足够久达到产卵年龄，它们可以使用嗅觉回到他那里，逆流而上直到它们来到孵化场旁边的溪床。
So Bill sets up a chute, which extends about 100 feet. It connects the truck to the edge of the pier. Then there's a 20-foot drop from the pier to the bay. Darkness finally closes in, and Bill signals that it's time. As oblivious teenagers make out at the end of the pier, a slow trickle of water drips down into the bay. Then a steady stream flows with a few of the small fish. Then a cascade, a rush all at once, crowded and alive. The salmon are falling in a flurry to the bay below, crashing against the water, then making small waves of their own.
两小时三十分钟后，卡车终于到达了目的地，贝克堡。在深夜之前什么都做不了，因为如果鲑鱼在光天化日之下被释放，海鸥、鹈鹕和鸬鹚就会盘旋、俯冲，吞下它们能吞下的那50万条鱼中的尽可能多。在我们面前，金门大桥勾勒出了旧金山湾，在天际线下闪烁。它们不能离水太近，因为码头是一个历史地标。
It's chaotic and beautiful, but everything about this is fucked up. It feels crude and kind of rude to the animals. I feel like we don't even deserve salmon, if this is the world we've made. But at the same time-- and I hate that I'm saying this-- it's not so bad. I love salmon, and I want them to survive. And if we're going to have salmon in California, this might be the only way. Bill repeats the process with each truck four more times. A few fish flop on the pier, and he picks them up tenderly and throws them in the water with the others. He's gotten them as far as he can.
所以比尔架起了一个大约100英尺长的滑槽。它连接卡车和码头边缘。然后从码头到海湾有20英尺的落差。黑暗终于笼罩了，比尔示意时间到了。当不知情的青少年在码头尽头亲热时，一滴水珠慢慢滴进海湾。然后一股稳定的水流带着几条小鱼流下。然后是一道瀑布，一股瞬间爆发的急流，拥挤而鲜活。鲑鱼在阵风中跌落到下面的海湾，撞击着水面，然后掀起属于它们自己的小波浪。
Jaime Lowe, her most recent book is called Breathing Fire, Female Inmate Firefighters on the Front Lines of California's Wildfires.
这很混乱，也很美丽，但关于这所有的一切都是操蛋的。它感觉很粗糙，而且对动物有点粗鲁。我觉得如果我们创造了这样的世界，我们甚至不配拥有鲑鱼。但与此同时——我讨厌我说这话——情况并没有那么糟糕。我爱鲑鱼，我想让它们生存。如果我们要在加州拥有鲑鱼，这可能是唯一的方法。比尔又重复了四次每辆卡车的过程。几条鱼在码头上扑腾，他温柔地把它们捡起来，扔进水里和其他鱼在一起。他已经把它们送到他所能送到的最远的地方了。
[MUSIC - "I'LL TAKE THE LONG ROAD" BY NAOMI SHELTON & THE GOSPEL QUEENS]
杰米·洛，她最近的一本书叫《呼吸之火》，讲述加州野火前线的女性囚犯消防员。
Well, our program was produced today by Chris Benderev and Nadia Reiman. The people who helped put together today's program include Bim Adewunmi, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Chana Joffe-Walt, Seth Lind, Michelle Navarro, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Alix Spiegel, Laura Starcheski, Christopher Swetala, Marisa Robertson-Textor, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
[音乐 - 娜奥米·谢尔顿和福音女王演唱的“我会走漫长的路”]
Special thanks today to Paloma Wu and Blake Feldman at the Mississippi Center for Justice, Arthur Bass, Carson Jeffres, Autumn Bernstein, Steve Gough, Alicia Netterville, Patricia Trowles, Jay Jackson, Omar Travis, Sam Levine, Pippa Holloway, Dorothy Overstreet Pratt, Kerri Cleeland, Rebecca Vitali-Decola, America Billy, and Rebecca Kanthor.
好了，我们今天的节目由克里斯·本德雷夫和纳迪亚·雷曼制作。帮助整合今天节目的人包括比姆·阿德温米、肖恩·科尔、迈克尔·科米特、阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德、查娜·乔菲-沃尔特、赛斯·林德、米歇尔·纳瓦罗、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、劳拉·斯塔切斯基、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、玛丽莎·罗伯逊-泰克斯特、马特·蒂尔尼和黛安·吴。我们的执行编辑是莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的资深编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 750 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there's videos. There's lists of favorite shows. There's tons of other stuff there, too. Seriously, it's good. Again, thisamericanlife.org.
特别感谢今天密西西比正义中心的帕洛玛·吴和布莱克·费尔德曼，阿瑟·巴斯、卡森·杰弗里斯、奥特姆·伯恩斯坦、史蒂夫·高夫、艾丽西亚·内特维尔、帕特里夏·特罗尔斯、杰伊·杰克逊、奥马尔·特拉维斯、萨姆·莱文、皮帕·霍洛威、多萝西·欧弗斯特里特·普拉特、克里·克里兰、丽贝卡·维塔利-德科拉、美国比利和丽贝卡·坎索尔。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He is still bitter, bitter, so bitter over Julie Andrews leaving him long ago, to star in the movie, Mary Poppins. He remembers telling her--
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以完全免费在线收听我们750多集节目的存档。此外，还有视频。有最喜欢的节目列表。上面还有很多其他东西。说真的，这很好。再次，thisamericanlife.org。
Have fun being able to spell supercalifragilisticexpialidocious.
《美国生活》由公共广播交换平台PRX传送给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托里·马拉蒂亚先生。他仍然很痛苦，痛苦，对于朱莉·安德鲁斯很久以前离开他去主演电影《欢乐满人间》感到如此痛苦。他记得告诉过她——
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
当你能拼出“supercalifragilisticexpialidocious”的时候去玩吧。